et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
marie beau et on bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci d'être là
vous êtes journaliste à la croix l'hebdo
et avec marianne meunier vous avez signé
ce dossier spécial qui s'appelle
terrorisme la prison et après le fruit
de plusieurs mois d'enquêté sur ce qu'on
appelle les sortants ces détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme ici en france
qui sortent de prison après avoir purgé
leur peine il incarne écrivez-vous le
mal suprême même eux doivent un jour
retrouver la liberté d'abord pourquoi
avez vous voulu faire cette enquête
parce qu'il pose un défi sécuritaire
énorme à la france on le sait peu mais
150 d'entre eux sont sortis ces deux
dernières années pour la seule année
2009 1 2 ils devraient être une centaine
et alors on se parle 415 sont encore
détenus soient en vie d'être jugés
soient déjà jugé c'est un défi
sécuritaire parce que si vous voulez
comme le dit très bien le directeur de
la pénitentiaire pendant un temps on a
parlé des revenants de syrie aujourd'hui
on a des sortants de prison il s'agit à
la fois s'assurer qu'il ne récidiveront
pas s'en empêcher pour autant leur
réinsertion et là on est sur une ligne
de crête extrêmement difficile on parle
d'hommes en majorité de quelques femmes
qui ont fait quoi qui ont été pour ceux
qui ont été condamnés condamné à quoi
alors en fait c'est vrai que la
qualification terroriste est extrêmement
large flou on a aussi bien des personnes
connues pour apologies terrorisme qui
ont eu un an deux ans trois ans de
prison et puis vous avez salle abdeslam
qui sans doute ne sortira jamais de
prison et puis vous avez le gros des
effectifs c'est le milieu du spectre des
personnes qui ont été en syrie ou qui
ont voulu y aller qui ont été arrêtés
avant ces personnes là pour beaucoup ont
été arrêtés en 2013 2014 2015 et ont
écopé en moyenne de 7 8 ans de prison
n'est en 2022 donc c'est l'heure de la
sortie pour beaucoup d'entre eux voilà
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui en réalité
ils sont plus nombreux à sortir de
prison ferme entre l'enjeu est double
vous le disiez à l'instant et pas des
moindres il est à la fois sécuritaire et
morale s'assurer effectivement que ce
qu'on appelle les ts les tice ne vont
pas récidiver tout en lampe tout en leur
permettant de se réinsérer sacré décès
ça et alors c'est vrai que si vous
voulez une fois qu'ils sont sortis de
prison et sont nécessairement suivi par
un service de renseignement soit
territoriale pour le battre spectre
comme on dit ce soit la dgs i qui peut
aller pour les plus gros profils jusqu'à
un suivi h 24 donc ça veut dire qu'on
mobilise plusieurs dizaines de
fonctionnaires et puis ils ont ils sont
soumis à un certain nombre de
contraintes pour certains il faut
pointer quotidiennement commissariat
interdiction de sortir de sa commune de
fréquenter certaines personnes rendez
vous serait régulier chez le juge suivi
psy obligatoire pour certains et donc
c'est vrai que leurs avocats disent
c'est une peine à perpétuité ils sont
sortis de prison mais vous en faites par
ces contraintes des débiteurs avis et le
risque et certains juges antiterroristes
eux reconnaissent eux mêmes c'est qu'on
alimente le mal qu'on est censé
combattre c'est à dire qu'on renforce
chez eux un ressentiment qui se retourne
un jour contre la société vous avez
rencontré un ex détenu qui raconte voilà
une situation kafkaïenne d'ailleurs il a
fini par retourner voilà il ne se
réveille pas à l'heure pour aller devant
le juge et donc il retourne en prison un
autre en sortant du bus sort du
territoire qui lui est imparti retourne
en prison
ce sont des faits absolument anodin dans
une vie quotidienne classique mais ces
personnes sont vus comme potentiellement
très dangereuse et si jamais selon les
autorités on les laisse comme ça filet
parce qu'ils ont une heure de retard à
un rendez vous ça peut avoir des
conséquences dévastatrices donc c'est
vrai que les autorités sont extrêmement
fébrile face à cette population là et
donc fait preuve d'une très grande
sévérité vis à vis d'eux et là on
revient aux défis posés par le
terrorisme et qui a été illustré par le
procès des attentats de novembre 2015
par celui celui qui se tient en ce
moment des attentats de nice le défi
posé à nos sociétés de ne pas déroger à
la règle de droit quand la justice passe
mais aussi quand la justice est passé
exactement et là indéniablement
certains disent j'ai l'impression que
j'ai pris perpet dehors c'est à dire
qu'ils sont sortis de prison mais ils
estiment qu'on les condamne à une
nouvelle forme de peine sans qu'on dise
sans qu'on le dise ouvertement du fait
qu'ils sont dangereux et la dangerosité
on le sait c'est un c'est un concept
extrêmement floue extrêmement plastique
il est extrêmement difficile d'évaluer
la dangerosité de certains de ces
profils alors ils sont soumis les trois
derniers mois de prison et sont soumis à
une évaluation pluridisciplinaire avec
des référents religieux des services de
renseignements qui sont face à eux des
psychologues l'idée étant de s'assurer
qu'ils ne pratiquent pas la fameuse
takia vous savez cet art de la
dissimulation qu'elle prenait dans la
littérature jihadiste et de s'assurer
que le désengagement dont il dit faire
preuve est bien réelle parce que les
profils effectivement sont
extraordinairement à différents vous
avez rencontré une ex détenus qui dit
avoir regretté inchangé voit ce qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait ce qui effectivement
font semblant d'une certaine façon de ne
plus y croire ceux qui n'ont pas bougé
d'un iota difficulté effectivement
extrême de savoir ce qu'ils vont faire
en plus parce que vous dites qu'il ya
une différence entre le taux de récidive
est très bas sur le court terme en
revanche pour le mal assurée pour le
long terme c'est là c'est toute la
spécificité du terrorisme c'est qu'on
peut fomenté un attentat sur des années
donc certes l'arrêt si aujourd'hui est
extrêmement faible mais peut pas
s'assurer que ce sera le cas à l'avenir
mais il faut quand même dire que la
récidive est très faible et qu'en
général ces personnes-là la dgsi dis
bien pour la majorité dont on n'entendra
plus parler d'eux simplement il ya un
biais dans l'opinion parce qu'on a on ne
parle pas de ce qu'ils ne récidivent pas
on va parler que de ceux qui sont
repassés à l'acte mais dans la majorité
des cas quand ils repassent à l'accès
pour des faits de droits communs comme
on dit c'est à dire vol d'armes trafic
mais pas à terrorisme sauf qu'il y en a
des contre exemples vous l'évoquez dans
votre enquête l'un des deux assassins du
père hamel à saint-etienne du rouvray
adèle kermiche avait passé était allé en
prison avait été condamné à quatre ans
de prison de mémoire avait été libéré
sous bracelet électronique ce qui n'a
pas empêché en effet de repasser à
l'acte et puis vous avez évidemment il
n'est pas encore jugé mais franck à
belle et longue qui assassine et yvan
colonna en prison alors qu'il n'était
pas un certain sens strict mais qu'ils
allaient l'être dans les mois qui venait
donc là aussi à récidive vous parliez de
désengagement tout à l'heure il y a
quelques années on parlait de
déradicalisation il me semble que ce
terme est de moins en moins employés
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des retours sur
les différents processus qui ont été mis
en place en prison notamment précisément
pour s'en assurer ou du moins la
compagnie oui alors on ne parle plus de
déradicalisation pour une raison très
près mais plutôt de désengagement la
violence parce qu'en france il ya pas de
délit d'opinion vous pouvez avoir des
idées radicales des convictions
extrémistes ce qui est condamné en
france c'est le fait de les matérialiser
dans un acte violent donc ce qui importe
c'est que ces personnes n'ont pas des
plus d'idées radicale mais se désengage
de l'action violente ensuite pour savoir
pour évaluer en effet leur degré d
engagement ça c'est très très difficile
ce qui est sûr c'est que la
pénitentiaire depuis cinq ans a mis en
place des dispositifs extrêmement
innovant sans doute est plus poussée
d'europe du fait aussi des vagues
sanglante de terroristes qu'on a connu
donc on évaluer ses personnages sont
évalués quand elles arrivent en prison
par une équipe pluridisciplinaire l'idée
étant de dire au fond la takia existe
cette dissimulation est possible mais
plus on met d'intervenants face à eux
plus il est difficile de mentir à
beaucoup de personnes un donc ils sont
vraiment évaluer à l'entrée ils sont
évalués à la sortie et en fonction de
leur degré de dangerosité supposée ils
vont avoir des comment dire un suivi
carcéral différencier et puis vous
raconter aussi en prison vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure le rôle des agents
de renseignements auprès de ces détenus
particulier racontez-nous peut-être
comment ça sourit alors depuis cinq ans
la france est un des rares pays au monde
a un qui fait ça à des agents de du
renseignement en prison qui d'ailleurs
aux yeux de leurs collègues surveillants
ce sont des surveillants langue dari n'y
a que le directeur de la détention qui
sait que ce sont des agents du
renseignement leur seul objectif c'est
le suivi des profits les plus à risque
donc ils vont faire en sorte de
retourner par exemple les amis des des
djihadistes ils vont faire en sorte de
sonoriser leurs cellules ils vont
s'assurer qu'ils ont un téléphone ce qui
est interdit en prison était fréquent
pour pouvoir intercepter leur
communication ces agents du
renseignement non pour vocation que de
suivre les profilés purgerait les tice
évidemment le son afin de renseigner
la dgs si les services de renseignement
territoriaux une fois que ces personnes
sortiront de détention avec toujours
cette tentative de marcher sur cette
ligne de crête kwc a du respect de
l'état de droit oui d'ailleurs certains
disent en fait on ne sait pas comment
faire pour ne plus vous faire peur or là
on voit bien qu une inversion de la
charge de la preuve en droit français
c'est à la justice de démontrer que vous
êtes dangereux et surtout que vous avez
commis un acte répréhensible
là ils ont purgé leur peine ils sortent
et ils disent mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est à moi de démontrer que je ne suis
plus dangereux ce qui est indéniablement
eux met à mal nos droits fondamentaux
tout comme le fait de leur imposer une
forme de peine alors même qu'ils ont
purgé au sens strict de débat qu'on a
entendu aussi a effectivement vous
l'avez évoqué à l'issue des procès du
procès de l'attentât du traite des
attentats du 13 novembre de la
condamnation à vie selon ses avocats de
salade et slam on parlait tout à l'heure
du défi que pose le terrorisme dans ce
respect de la norme juridique en france
la france qui vient d'être condamné pour
son refus de rapatrier des familles de
djihadistes et de syrie ça aussi ça pose
un problème à la fois sécuritaire et
morale oui tout à fait et morale c'est
une évidence dire qu'on ne peut pas
interdire à priori à un ressortissant
français de rentrer en france
sécuritaire aussi parce que la france a
tellement attendu contrairement à nos
voisins européens que les juges qui vous
disent au fond ces enfants ces femmes ce
sont potentiellement des bombes à
retardement on a tellement attendu qu'en
effet on a alimenté un ressentiment
vis-à-vis de ces personnes que
finalement nous rapatrierons et la
boucle est bouclée vous l'aura que vous
le disiez tout à l'heure le risque avec
ces ex détenus c'est is kill que lors la
situation kafkaïenne dans laquelle
certains se retrouvent viennent
alimenter un discours de haine à l'égard
de la france là c'est la même c'est la
même chose peut-être pour ça sans doute
plus encore centaines de femmes et 250
enfants enfermés encore dans des camps
du nord de la syrie merci infiniment
merci marie beau et on d'être venu nous
parler de cette enquête qui ne datent
pas de cette semaine mais voilà on a été
bousculés dans notre programmation je
pense qu'on peut encore là la trouver et
puis on peut la trouver en ligne bien
sûr la croix l'hebdo terroriste la
prison et après enquête que vous cosigné
avec marianne meunier
merci infiniment d'être venu vous en
parlait ce matin on se retrouve juste
après la pause pour la suite de paris
direct avec pauline godard à temps
[Musique]